my name is victor negrasco i joined the
snd group eva ponova epp group 40 may
not seem like a magic number especially
when you're a little bit younger but if
you are 40 or under and you're elected
to the european parliament you're part
of an elite club the young emmy peace
club
some 90 young meps were elected this
parliamentary term and here at the
parliament a training event to help get
them settled in
so to find out a little bit more about
the event i'm here with adam who's one
of the organizers so adam why are we
having an event like this i mean what's
the sort of purpose behind it well i
mean
you the network of u40 is there to serve
young members of the european parliament
and inform them about the pitfalls and
show them a little bit how they can get
a good start into the parliament and
maybe not make the mistakes that many of
their predecessors have made if you have
an office uh with with too much high
qualified staff and too little high
qualified work to do then there will be
frustration there will be backstabbing
there will be jealousy and envy and it
will create a poisonous atmosphere in
your team and if you want to stand up
from the pack a key ingredient courting
the press they will be confronted with
with us with the press
it's good to tell them what are the
basic rules
explain for example what is on the
record what is of the record
why they should not perhaps spam us with
a lot of press releases but perhaps
make a phone call
but the biggest lesson to be learned
here was strategy it's choosing your
battles it's understanding what's
important and what's not i think the
choice of your committee is essential if
you look at um someone like jean philip
albrecht for example who came in as i
think 26 27 five years ago and how he
played social media right from the
beginning and how he made himself a name
but does being young add any value in
the eu 2014 elections the turnout was
low at just 43.1 percent despite huge
media campaigns to get young people out
voting it made little difference in the
end the disenfranchised remained aloof
the fact that we are young matters and
engaging the youth and re-engaging and
finding ways to reengage the youth the
european youth with with politics and
re-legitimize politics in the process is
a crucial crucial issue for europe for
the long term i think okay so there you
have it they learned a few new tricks
understood better the role they need to
play over the next five years let's see
now how they do